Earlier this morning, when I wanted to shower,
I realized that we ran out of soap.
Luckily, a couple hours later,
my husband landed back home and got straight into making me some.
I struggle with eczema and sensitive skin,
so today we went with a lavender oatmeal soap.
In the meantime, he heated up some water on the stove,
set his metal bowl over it,
and let that melt while he started grinding up some oats.
Once our soap base had melted,
he poured half of it into a separate bowl
before combining it with some lavender
essential oil and some purple mica powder.
He gave that really good mix until it was all combined,
sprayed down the mold with some alcohol
before pouring the soap mixture into it.
While that was setting, he combined,
giving that a good stir before adding some more essential oils into it
and then pouring that on top of our purple soap base,
topped it with some more lavender,
and let that set for about four to six hours.
Six hours? He cut it up into bars.
All the bars we weren't using,
I tied up before taking the other ones up to our shower.
I'm so glad we're stocked up.